qu'est ce que tu fais là je ne
raconterai mais nouveau colloque par
dirt craquer c'est sa maman moi je m'en
fous de lui un celle est en excès j'ai
réfléchi ça va c'est pas comme si je
n'avais jamais vu un poil en fait n'en
avais pas dit oui
jaurès j'ai pas j'ai pas voulu le faire
tout de suite je voulais pas faire 2 2
le 1 il avait bien marché les
personnages voilà les gens se sont
attachés aux personnages ont aimé le
sujet on hamm est le message qu on
transmettait dedans je voulais pas
repartir sur un 2 clairement parce que
j'avais peur de ne pas faire aussi bien
que le un voilà sachant que on a fait un
très bon score au cinéma et que c'est
pas donné à tout le monde donc moment je
voulais rester là dessus moi j'ai voilà
je veux rester sur cette petite victoire
maintenant on nous a proposé un très
beau scénario une belle suite c'est un
challenge de reprendre les personnages
qu'on a trouvé dans le premier dans le 2
qui ont grandi qu'on voit là qui ont
évolué que c'est un peu plus mûr donc
donc nord après voilà on le fait on
retrouve tous les copains et on est
content et voilà c'est très bien et moi
j'étais ravie de faire une suite
moi c'est quand on nous a annoncé
officiellement que c'était bon c'était
parti on allait faire une suite
quand j'ai lu le scénario j'étais ultra
motivés j'avais hâte de retrouver le
personnage est là de deux tournées avec
des copains voilà
[Musique]
moi c'était pas des retrouvailles
puisque depuis
premier tama on sait jamais vraiment
douté on est devant une très potes et on
se voit très très très souvent donc ce
qui est super c'est de refaire un film
ensemble de rentrer si l'équipe
technique ont qui avait tourné avec nous
en belgique il ya deux ans et demi on
fabrique en belgique
je pense que dans mon personnage son
évolution juste et qu'il est plus
extraverti que dans le premier mois j'ai
essayé de le faire vraiment fidèle au
premier
j'essaie de faire vraiment le même rôle
voilà il a évolué un petit peu il a plus
d'amis ils rigolent plus ivan plus mais
ça reste le même il est toujours
focalisé sur sa natation il l'a toujours
dit regarde toujours tamara d'un petit à
d'un petit côté avec des petits yeux qui
pétillent et non voilà j'ai vraiment
essayé de garder le même personnage et
pas te voilà il a grandi physiquement
ils vont j'ai changé depuis depuis le
premier tamara ouais j'ai pris une
petite j'ai pris une petite booba je
t'avoue que ouais et puis mes cheveux
bon c'est pas avant pas tout le monde
qui aime mais tant pis pour le moment
c'est comme ça oh mercy tamara merci moi
aussi je t'adore rendre vraiment mais
c'est le moment c'est le ft moment que
la mémé
non mais mon personnage il lâcherait
donc des gens fait physiquement je pense
que ça fait déjà la moitié du boulot
dans le sens où on le retrouve vraiment
plus tard et et maintenant voilà j'ai
essayé de le faire avancer un petit peu
avec ce que j'ai vécu aussi dans ma vie
je le fais évoluer moi aussi j'ai fait
de la coloc j'ai essayé de le voilà de
le rendre un peu plus amusant que le
premier et amaral a beaucoup changé
tamara dans le premier elle était
complexée c'était l'adolescente qui
était très peu sûre d'elle elle
subissait des beaucoup de mots créa au
lycée et n'avaient jamais eu de petit
copain et après on a eu des goûts là
dans le dos on la retrouve à l'aise
on la retrouve motivé dalle pour changer
de vie elle est déterminée elle veut
monter sur paris elle est là plein
d'ambition plaindre et vente est
vraiment tourné la page de toutes ces
années de souffrance est très très sûre
d'elle elle s'enflamme beaucoup trop
trouve un peu trop sûre d'elle ah ouais
bah oui c'était encore plus drôle parce
que du coup c'est on se lance des piques
on se charrie tamara les jalouses de la
copine de diego donc ses collages rsa
aussi deux amis qui jouent l'amour c'est
compliqué parce que voilà on est potes
on se chambre tous les jours voilà onze
vannes à longueur de journée et puis le
moment
un moment venu on est dans la merde un
allez va maintenant on va s'embraser
donc ouais nan là dedans le 2 était
beaucoup plus simple dans le sens où on
avait une coloc c'était que de la
rigolade c'est ces voix là on est je
pense qu'on a vraiment fait comme dans
la vie de tous les jours parce que tamar
ans voir dehors on est on est on est
très proches très amis et donc voilà le
2 en tout cas c'était encore plus simple
à faire enfin encore plus simple dans le
doubs bah ça a été plus simple en tout
cas à faire que le numéro je suis un
petit coeur moi j'aime bien
j'aime bien que ça se passe bien non moi
du coup non
pour être même totalement franc mon père
m'avait dit une phrase il m'avait dit
mon fils y est pour moi la les ex voile
avait comme la prison ceux qui
retournent c'est que t'as rien compris
ouais ouais petit philosophe poète
philosophe pourquoi voudrais je suis un
peu un canard dans le sens dans le sens
où ouais quand je suis avec caen avec
quelqu'un je fais plein de choses un peu
bête ou pas par amour mais en tout cas
voilà je les fais avec le coeur je me
dis qu'un sensible et un peu ouais ouais
ouais voilà c'est comme ça j'ai pas mais
j'ai fait pas mal de trucs m'apprécient
les trucs là on achète faire tapis de
roses ont fait oui c'est oui voilà ouais
ça fait envie did ouais voilà bon écoute
on est en entente entendre des petits
trucs qu'on veut faire plaisir faut être
innovant donc dans la vie de tous les
jours j'aime bien faire plaisir à
l'autre j'aime bien
j'aime bien cuisiner j'aime bien mettre
des bougies grèce en bon j'aime bien moi
je pense que je suis assez romantique
j'ai un pari que tente t care tomou donc
c'est possible c'est en fait ça dépend
le premier on n'était pas censés faire
un deuxième il a marché les gens on en
redemande et nous la fondation deux là
si les gens hors demande si les gens
adorent si le film marche
nous on serait ravi de faire une
trilogie
je veux dire la vérité j'ai pas besoin
d'un tamara 3 pour revoir mes amis c'est
tamara ces voix là on est on est tous
amis on peut se voir ailleurs maintenant
voilà cesser si vraiment on fait 1 3
c'est parce qu'il ya une suite logique
parce que parce que encore une fois ces
quelques années plus tard qu'on passe
par une autre étape de la vie que voilà
faut que ce soit faut que ce soit un
beau film
on a fait un inquiéter qui étaient
étaient pas mal on a fait 1 2 qui je
trouve moi et mieux falloir va falloir
faire mieux pour le 3 sinon il y aura
pas de 3
si tu regarde un peu autour de toi tu
faire il ya plein de gens qui t'aiment
à
oui le 4 avril 93 et je suis pas né le 4
juin et 9 rebonds elle est née le 27
juin
huawei 1980 14 15 16 16
non m marine mélanie marine marine ou
pierre faye lâchement à une première
lettre de 3 à temps non non non non non
gaspard gabriel ok bah ouais bah tamara
à tamar et tamar est dû qu tamar et dudu
vomito way
être en retard naïve très naïve
alors vécu dans une dans une ronde de 12
mètres carrés sans fenêtres et en coloc
tamarelle a pas fait de colloque m et
elle est partie en vacances plusieurs
mois avec avec avec des amis et ce
qu'elle aime pas tamara c'est les gens
qui sont sales et ceux qui ont des tue
l'amour c'est ces moments de la danse on
a une chorégraphie qui a été fait par
dénis tricot nova et un moment où elle
tourne et on a dansé sur les plateformes
haute d'un mètre par mètre trente comme
à son habitude tamara raté la plateforme
elle s'est littéralement voilà elle
s'est littéralement jetée dans le vide
sur une pauvre dame kyi qui tenait une
coupe de champagne qui avait rien
demandé à personne à qui elle a cassé le
poignet et la coupe de champagne si
thammarat il fait de la natation il
entraîne un
un gamin qui débute mais pour le film
ils ont ils ont pris des acteurs qui
savent et supérieur nager c'était des
professionnels s'étaient même pas des
acteurs et ils ont cast est ce cet
enfant et quand il est entré dans l'eau
et que alexandra 10 actions il a coulé
mounir c'est mounir qui jouait pas au
sam hamad et qui est dans sa vie depuis
très longtemps depuis l'enfance son
meilleur ami en fait je dirais jimmy
labo
craquer c'est sa maman moi je m'en fous
de lui un c'est juste un mec sans je
réfléchis mais tu me ramènes montrer la
gare le monde et dix ans plus ancien et
et clients au niveau qui fait le phare
je pars je me sens pas un gars va lui
faire du mal
et encore avec elle fait ça et ça va pas
en quoi c'est cool d'être à bout